et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le maire de caen merci de nous
accueillir ce soir dans cette ville
chère à mon coeur où je fus formé
pendant près de sept années où j'ai
beaucoup partagé ou ma famille réside
encore et qui pour moi est une référence
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette ville cher
laurent que je me suis engagé
c'était en classe de première c'était
dans une formation politique un peu
particulière qui s'appelait l'union
démocratique du travail chez les
gaullistes sociaux et je dois dire que
c'est un souvenir extrêmement précis
pour moi de mon engagement politique
voyez que j'ai pas beaucoup varié
bien sûr saluer le successeur de
guillaume le conquérant
hervé morin et lui adresser un message
je le dis avec beaucoup de respect
fidélité devant toi bruche nac pour
lequel j'ai très grand respect au droit
illac su construire l'unité de cette
normandie que nous mettions dans nos
intentions de prière et comme dans nos
intentions de prière ça n'arrive jamais
ce que nous disons lui il a réussi et je
dois dire que cette amende il me permet
de saluer tous les parlementaires de
cette normandie là qu'ils viennent de
l'eure de la seine maritime de la manche
du calvados et de l'orne avec une
mention particulière parce que je
retrouve des sénateurs appartenant aux
deux groupes de la majorité sénatoriale
hervé je voudrais le dire sonia rate ça
me fait grand plaisir de la retrouver ce
soir avec toi c'est un petit clin d'oeil
particulier
tout comme de retrouver philippe bas et
les autres de dire aussi à l'ensemble
des élus maires conseillers régionaux
conseillers départementaux combien votre
engagement est tout à fait essentiel
dans les temps qui viennent et que pour
le renouveau de nos familles politiques
vous êtes des maillons particulièrement
fort et puis vous ne m'en voudrez pas de
citer un élu mais c'est mon département
natal ans christophe de balorre le
président du conseil départemental de
l'orne
je n'oublie pas que c'est là que je suis
né c'est là que j'ai passé mon enfance
c'est là où j'ai été formé comme
vétérinaire au haras du pin et ça reste
pour moi une véritable référence mais
passé le temps des souvenirs
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais dire à laurent wauquiez que
le sens de ma présence ce soir aux côtés
de françois xavier bellamy de lui-même
et d'hervé morin
un vrai sens politique chacun sait que
j'ai pu interroger un moment mais que
les choses soient claires je ne suis pas
des bouts de lèvres dans la campagne
je suis totalement dans cette campagne
j'en fais même pour moi pour reprendre
une formule qui plaira à françois-xavier
une forme de devoir d'état au sens
étymologique du devoir d'état
c'est en effet je crois une
responsabilité collective que nous avons
républicain amis centristes autour
d'hervé morin de d'obtenir le meilleur
résultat et d'envoyer enfin un message
mais j'y reviendrai dans un instant oui
nous devons nous rassembler et nous
rassembler
c'est le préambule le prologue c'est
l'ouverture en quelque sorte nécessaires
à d'autres reconquête qui sont les
nôtres et pour lesquels nous nous fixons
l'objectif demain pas simplement de
figurer mais de l'emporter c'est
l'objectif que nous nous fixons à
l'image de ce que nous vivons sénat dans
le rassemblement dans la capacité
parfois l'indépendance nous sommes
parfois pas toujours difficile à
conduire
mais cette liberté cet espace est pour
nous quelque chose d'essentiel la
campagne européenne est sur les rails
refonder l'europe rétablir la france
mais je dois dire que nous avons
rarement vu une campagne se dérouler
dans de telles conditions
une crise
social sont pressés dans un climat qu'on
a pu qualifier par fouad insurrectionnel
un grand débat qui s'est éternisée et
qui a certes montré la tante de dialogue
de nos compatriotes mais dont les
conclusions points de suspension laisse
déjà un avant goût de tout ça pour ça
une parole présidentielle qui a été
tardive scénarisé et qui au fond nous le
savons déjà ne pourra que décevoir
enfin quelques irréductibles gilet jaune
entre ultras jaune et ultra gauche qui
pense toujours être l'expression du
peuple profond dans la soi-disant
légitimité des réseaux sociaux avec la
légitimité des urnes
la dernière séquence policiers suicidez
vous a définitivement disqualifié à mes
yeux je ne doute pas à vos yeux ce
mouvement ne l'oublions jamais police et
gendarmerie sont les piliers du respect
du droit et de la démocratie
je crois qu'il est bon de le réaffirmer
nous sommes donc dans la tente de gelée
mis entre guillemets de la vraie
intervention du président de la
république qui a été précédée d'une
intervention non prononcé en raison bien
sûr de la tragédie de notre dame de
paris qui nous a tous touchés
d'ailleurs quelle semaine lundi pack
descendre le dimanche pâques de sang au
sri lanka
je crois que nous ne devons pas non plus
le balayer au nom de la distance mais
dans les valeurs que nous partageons
oui entre vrais interventions et
intervention prononcée une méthode
étrange
la france est un pays qui se fragmente
et qui en dehors d'événements
exceptionnels catastrophe les attentats
mois et cela m'inquiète progressivement
disparaître les attributs constitutive
d'une nation c'est jérôme fourquet le
directeur général de l'ifop qui le
décrit la france devient un archipel
constitué d'îles ou qui ne communiquent
plus qui ne se comprennent plus or la
solution à la crise d'identité à la
crise sociale que nous traversons ne
peut se résumer à une déclinaison de
mesures catégorielles sur le pouvoir
d'achat la fiscalité ou la crise de la
représentation
si tel était le cas ils ne réussiront
pas jamais la diversité des propositions
de coïncidera avec la diversité et les
attentes des catégories concernées
certes les français attendent des
annonces fort et symbolique mais sans
cap sans objectif atteint sans fil
conducteur sans l'idée que tout doit
concourir un grand dessein pour le pays
il sera difficile d'emporter l'adhésion
de nos concitoyens je crois que les
français attendent une vision au delà
des mots un souffle et les actes la
déclaration présumer que nous avons tous
lu du président de la république ne me
paraît pas s'inscrire dans cette veine
là elle a de plus l'inconvénient
d'alimenter des débats regarder ce
week-end voire des polémiques pour une
série de propositions non aboutis que
veut dire travailler plus point
d'interrogation que veut dire plus de
proportionnelle
que peut dire simplification du
millefeuille amour tant de fois entendu
le saupoudrage de quelques mesures
coûteuses fait d'ailleurs sur le déficit
budgétaire ou d'annoncés roland un peu
démagogique ne règleront rien il faut
s'attaquer aux racines du mal
les racines du mal chers amis nous les
connaissons ses racines s'appelle sur
fiscalité avec le taux de prélèvement le
plus élevé du monde 46 2 % 12 points de
plus que la moyenne de l'eau c d e
comment voulez vous que la question du
consentement la peau ne soit pas posée
comment voulez vous créer les conditions
d'une société dynamique
les racines du mal on s'appelle aussi
nous ne cessons de le répéter niveau de
la dépense publique c'est notre deuxième
record européen
alors le président de la république doit
nous expliquer pourquoi avec un tel taux
de prélèvement il ya tel niveau de
dépenses publiques la france est encore
soumise à des sanctions social aussi
forte et un tel sentiment d'inéquité oui
il est temps de se poser la question de
l'efficacité de la dépense publique
troisième racine du mal que je vois elle
s'appelle sentiments pour une partie de
nos concitoyens de ne plus compter
d'être à côté qu'il est toujours plus
difficile de s'en sortir de se faire
entendre
entre métropolisation mondialisation et
financiarisation et que ce cri de la
france d'un côté il ne faut pas non plus
le mépriser ou l'oublier c'est celui
aussi qui s'est exprimé au mois de
novembre
nous devons le prendre en compte une
partie nos concitoyens n'ont plus
réellement le sentiment profond qu'ils
appartiennent à la même république que
certains c'est un point sur lequel nous
parce que avec nos amis centristes
nous revendiquons le mot républicain
nous devons être
culièrement attentif un mot sur la
réforme des institutions
les français demandent à être mieux
représentés et mieux écouter alors ce
serait moins d'élus plus de
proportionnelle
un référendum d'initiative partagée
améliorer un référendum d'initiative
citoyenne réservé aux aux sujets locaux
une assemblée de citoyens tirés au sort
et une révision constitutionnelle
renvoyer cher philippe bas à la sagesse
des assemblées est ce une réponse de
fond à une démocratie représentative
fragilisé et à une meilleure association
des citoyens à la prise de décisions
dont les citoyens ont besoin c'est de
plus de proximité et je le dis plus de
proximité c'est aussi cher hervé morin
chers collègues élus régionaux
départementaux chers collègues maires
d'une nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation dont nous avons besoin
pour sortir le pays de l'ornière dans
laquelle il est cette affirmation là ne
doit pas être que des mots mais se
traduire pleinement dans les faits alors
chers amis il faut redonner à notre pays
un souffle il faut créer une société de
participation et de lien social et je
vous conseille de relire un texte qui
est complètement dépassée aujourd'hui
mais simplement pour se poser une
question
ce texte dès 1969 il est jacques chaban
delmas
il s'appelle le discours sur la nouvelle
société
certes la société d'aujourd'hui n'a plus
rien à voir avec la société de 1969
mais il n'empêche que nous responsables
it nous devons nous poser la question de
notre réponse et de notre projet demain
face à une société qui aujourd'hui
s'exprime de la manière dont elles
s'expriment et dont nous avons le devoir
de porter un certain nombre de réponses
alors mes chers amis nous abordons la
ligne droite des élections européennes
j'oserais dire à nous trois candidats
normand à françoise guégot que je
retrouve avec bonheur toujours j'allais
lire plein d'engagement et de fidélité
leurs nerfs à cette agricultrice de
l'orne que pour bien connaître ce
département ces paroles étaient à la
fois forte juste et en vérité et aux
chasseurs de la manche que dans le
gabion du mont saint michel ou de
sallenelles j'ai pu partager les mêmes
passions que lui mais parlons europe par
l'or
l'europe est un enjeu majeur pour
l'avenir de notre pays
il n'y aura pas de france prospère dans
une europe en déclin cet enjeu dépasse
toutes les divergences que nous avons pu
exprimer
nous pouvons avoir des sensibilités
diverses des parcours différents mais je
le redis l'enjeu européen impose notre
rassemblement autour de la liste menée
par françois vous aviez bellamy nous
adversaires politiques chère hervé c'est
vrai il avait déjà fixé leur règle a eu
du jeu vous êtes pour l'europe alors
vous votez pour la république en marche
et d'ailleurs ça vaut une tranche de
côte de boeuf de saône et loire avec ave
gamme parisien ça fait une liste
cohérente
vous êtes contre l'europe alors vous
votez rassemblement la chaîne à moi je
refuse cette vision manichéenne que l'on
voulait nous imposer une autre voie est
possible la nôtre nous sommes avec nos
amis centristes
le mouvement politique et fondateur de
l'europe
nous sommes avec le parti populaire
européen le premier parti du parlement
européen celui qui va compter nous
porter une vision de l'europe qui doit à
la fois protéger affronter les
difficultés au lieu de les contourner
nous sommes en mettant une europe qui
refusons le mythe fédéraliste d1 et
l'euroscepticisme des autres nous sommes
pour l'europe
mais plus que les discours ou les
tribunes nous voulons contribuer aux
solutions concrètes pour que les
citoyens retrouvent confiance en ce
projet construit il y a plus de 60 ans
sur les décombres cher joël bruneau d'un
drame que cette ville apporter encore
plus que d'autres
notre projet en soi xavier mesdames y
reviendra dans quelques instants
il est ambitieux courageux fidèles à
notre histoire mais demandons nous quels
ont été les avancées réelles de l'europe
depuis l'élection du manuel
l'axé franco allemand est plus que
jamais malmenés ils n'étaient que d'être
à la conférence des présidents de
parlements nationaux de l'union
européenne à vienne
il y a deux semaines je peux vous dire
pour y avoir participé
et être largement intervenue que l'axé
franco allemand est plus que jamais
malmenés même si monsieur chat aube le
président du bundestag est bien plus
proche de nous que la chancelière angela
merkel jamais l'union européenne n'a été
en fait aussi fracturé le bras excite
nous paralyse aucune avancée perceptif
sur les grands sujets qui fragilise
notre cohésion
je veux évoquer la crise migratoire
c'est une réalité même si ce fut un
sujet interdit je serai
jeudi toute la journée à hendaye avec le
vice président de la commission des lois
pour faire sur pièces et sur place le
schéma de la réalité du phénomène
migratoire venant d'espagne
oui l'europe de la défense hervé le
mythe de l'armée européenne tant que la
constitution allemande ne sera pas
changée par les d'armée européenne et à
contre sens institutionnel politique à
une prise de responsabilité que je ne
comprends pas de la part du chef des
armées
je le dit gravement je le dis sans
emphase mais on ne peut pas faire croire
aux françaises et aux français
autant il nous faut construire des
convergences en matière de défense
d'industrie de défense
encore faudra-t-il jeu reprend la
formule de schaub le mot répandant dans
un discours à vienne
c'est vrai nous sommes le problème de
l'europe de la défense
la défense de nos intérêts économiques
face à la volonté égoïste des états unis
de la chine ou de la russie qui sont en
train de se partager le monde c'est vrai
l'europe ne va pas très bien
elle veut elle a voulu s'occuper de tout
alors qu'on lui demande de gérer
l'essentiel
alors mes chers amis aucune tribune
aucun discours futile à la sorbonne ne
fera disparaître l'échec de notre
politique européenne et la paire
d'affluence de la france quel leadership
vous leur accordez quand on est brouillé
avec la moitié des états membres
moi je ne me résous pas à une vision de
l'europe qui dans un axe syracuse danse
verrai quand on remonte à tribord les
forces du mal et à bâbord les forces du
bien
l'union européenne se sont les 27 avec
leur personnalité leur histoire et ne
demandons pas à des pays qui ne sont
rentrés dans la liberté
et oui il y a moins de 30 ans d'aller
dire de prendre avec le même bras le
corps un certain nombre de sujets oui
quel leadership vous leur accordez comme
nous sommes incapables de tenir nos
propres engagements sur la réduction des
déficits cas leadership vouloir incarner
quand la france projette depuis des mois
ces images de deshors et pourtant moi
comme hervé morin je crois à l'idéal
européen
je crois que l'idéal européen est intact
et que seule une europe forte peut
prétendre jouer un rôle dans le concert
des nations
seule une amphore peut tenter de fixer
les règles du jeu ces monstres que sont
devenus les gaffes à qui ont bouleversé
les règles de l'économie mondiale et
menacent d'ailleurs notre souveraineté
encore plus que d'autres puissances
mobilisons nos donc avec nos différences
rien ne serait pire pour notre pays
qu'il y ait à nos républiques and land
entre la république en marche et le
rassemblement national
oui parce que xavier à nous le dire
soyons fiers de notre histoire de notre
projet de la civilisation dont nous
sommes les héritiers du christianisme à
la réforme des lumières à la volonté de
bâtir la paix et voyez que je re boucle
avec ni monsieur hervé morin dans mon
évocation notre identité culturelle qui
évoque souvent français xavier bel ami
et je le pense
la vocation universaliste d'autres pays
de la renaissance à aujourd'hui
c'est là qu'un curieux d'idées nouvelles
la diffusion vidéo de liberté le
triomphe de la raison sur les systèmes
féodaux et l'arbitraire la france est
encore plus une volonté qu'a territoire
on s'y attache par le choeur et par
l'esprit autant que par les racines ce
n'est pas de moi d'alain finkielkraut et
chaque nation est constitutive de
l'europe alors
je vous propose avec mon sac j'ai vu un
bel ami avec l'ensemble de nos policiers
de partager la devise de l'europe unie
dans la diversité
vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]